and energy at that time it's okay we
have to have that car open and ready
because she has an issue with the car
she doesn't want to be part of it so I
needed to make sure her mind was in a
very forward mode and then keep moving
keep moving keep moving and just go
inside the car
just the fact that she put her two feet
on the bumper that told me okay so she's
not a Gaines the cottage she was again
smaller the way she went into the car so
okay how can I help her to feel invited
to go into the car so you know steps
this time this time what I did is I
grabbed a little bit and then I put her
feet here uh-huh
and then she finished she did right if I
just do the whole thing she never did
anything that's what I've been doing we
have to create a negative a positive on
this hot summer day Cesar uses water to
soothe and refresh olive
this also helps to lower her anxiety wet
the muzzle with the muscle
good right good job
you know didn't do it the fast way until
the tail relaxes before Caesar arrived
this morning I looked at my wife I said
honey I don't think he's gonna be able
to make anything happen I think that
she's not gonna get in the truck and it
happened quickly too she liked the step
oh my lord
she liked the step right Wow
see this is not drooling from the
anxiety this is just hot she's hot so
that would be a time for you to bring
her out and bite her out there see there
we go
notice that when I went and reached it
Lily she moved forward she didn't backed
away so I'm already becoming a positive
association as far as she's concerned
with her right yeah I'm gaining her
trust up this is not about respect this
is about trust so the respect comes
later if I could have done a backflip I
would have because I was floor I
couldn't believe I thought leave yeah
today they saw a way that this can be
done so they can finish their trust
relationship and eventually she just
jump into the car it's not that she can
jump so it's really good very good very
good perfect time to give affection we
go for spend so then that was the
association car means calm submission
car today doesn't mean frustration
trapped scare
breathing fast yes but not drooling so
now we're gonna make it a little bit
more comfortable for her in there with a
wet towel Wow any hot dog would
appreciate a wet floor see the
expression cool as a cucumber that was
the association that I wanted to create
this is a place where you become calm
submissive and cooled down house that
people have told us she may never change
you have to accept that about her and
now we suggested it she's changed that
she has changed and we've changed to
help her close it door I know what to do
now
I don't you feel right I think all is
gonna be a happy healthy dog
we were excluding her from fun
activities because of the car and now I
don't have to exclude her so that's
wonderful feeling
you